so leute jetzt
erstmal
rolls royce fahrersitz ist das geil
kommt das cruisen hat er
das also das will das habe ich das
richtig richtig geil überraschung herzen
kommt sollte man folglich fahrer leute
wir sind heute in köln foto motor world
und heute drehen wir mit einem ganz
besonderen gast cable freut mich sehr
groß aber kein sommer ohne
auto hier na ja bei dem wetter steht ja
noch drinnen da ich würde sagen ich gebe
mal holen na ja sehr gern ich bin sehr
gespannt was ich heute ganz wichtig
heute bevor es losgehen mit dem fahren
kann hat auch einen eigenen
youtube-kanal jetzt am start highlights
den habe ich eingeladen haben oder ja
sehr geil habe ich eine beschreibung
verlinkt erst hatte ich bin sehr gerne
ab und kommen dann kommt auch ein video
von spike ich habe eine weile bitte an
euch leute die leider nicht so witzig
ist und zwar ist ein freund von mir in
der nacht des 26
september 2020 um circa 31 in köln sehr
sehr schwer verletzt worden und ist
gerade so mit dem leben davonkommt wird
immer noch nach den tätern gefahren und
deswegen ein aufruf an euch falls ihr an
dem abend nacht 25.000 26 der neunte in
köln unterwegs war oder jemanden kennt
der unterwegs war ich habe euch einen
artikel dazu verlinkt zweiter link in
der beschreibung schreckt das ab und
schaut dann gerne mal rein wenn jemand
kennt da war oder ihr selbst da wartet
dann meldet euch auf jeden fall bei der
dort angegebenen telefonnummer und helft
mit die täter zu finden das war mir sehr
sehr sehr wichtigen herzensanliegen weil
der dem ja der junge hat nichts falsch
gemacht und sich gerade so davon
gekommen also auch in helfta gerne mit
und jetzt gehts weiter mit dem video
[Gelächter]
ja ich habe mir gedacht also ferrari
kann ja jeder und vier hat ist die
mutter von ferrari sie hat gehört dass
alles höre dann habe ich gedacht du
musst auch mal ein ordentliches auto
staiger guck mal mit liebe gemacht ja
das ist tatsächlich sehr geile aus ich
weiß wohl nicht obwohl bei dem wetter
die ganzen 22 ps ausfahren können auf
der hinterachse nur natürlich okay alles
klar dann spring ich mal rein sitzt gut
haben wir nicht so viel luxus haben wir
nicht
ein andermal
das ist noch ohne servo bremse ich bin
mal 300 sl gefahren das war auch richtig
richtig fahren aber habe ich es bekommen
bei der bremse ja ich habe auch so
mittlerweile alles was rang und namen
hat gefahren aber trotzdem ich finde die
autos früher hatten viel mehr geduld als
heutzutage heute die ähneln sich alle
zuseher egal was es ist bist du ein
freund für eine das gefühl hast du sitzt
in einem raumschiff und nur noch
computer hängt davon ab was du warst du
hast wenn du jetzt auf komfort
langstrecke fahren willst du dich so
raum schon gar nicht cool aber sondern
das fahren an sich man hat es ja nicht
hier setzt du dich rein macht ihn war er
zuerst nichts achten na das anstellen
das hochfahren das einstellen hier was
eingeben und bevor du nicht irgendwie so
ein elektro studium gemacht hast dann
weißt du das ding zu gewinnen ist da
werde ich immer wahnsinnig ich habe
letztens auf einer front formiert tesla
gefahren ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
finde das spartanische liebig denn lob
ich mir doch auch wirklich dann so einen
alten 911 ausklinken nach auto das ist
ein autors mir fehlt einfach ich bin da
etwas anna hier ich mir fehlt das
motorengeräusch irgendwann wurde ich
meine hier ist natürlich das ist ja
selbst passieren welche scheider ich
traue mich gar nicht was sie bedeuten
ich meine ich sehe diese diese sitze
diese farbe dieses babyblau das ist
einfach süß also würde ich auf jeden
fall das ist in der innenstadt sich
schön heiß holen ja genau sondern auf
dem ersten date so nett und zigaretten
ja das haben immerhin dass alle becher
immerhin aschenbecher also wir haben
keinen drehzahlmesser keine tankanzeige
leute kommen warum jetzt immer ein
problem sei übrigens bewusst der start
stopp knopf
sorry für meinen kampf schuhe heute
hammer gleiches problem wenn ihr mal die
pedalerie und anschaut und noch krasser
war beim 300 sl da hast du wirklich gar
hier immerhin haben sie das pedal nach
unten gesetzt beim dsl ist das noch hier
oben und hast du gar keine chance damit
so modernen fliegern irgendwie gas und
bremse zu unterscheiden das habe ich
schon meine rennschuhe an hier
er geht an beim ersten versuch ich bin
begeistert hierbei geschaltet wir dürfen
ja erstes rechts vorne haben fahren wir
einfach hier meine runde
so also
wieder leute hier vibrationsarm
unterwegs irgendwas hat auch eben
geknallt wir wissen nicht was er das
auch erfährt noch erfährt was aber tür
geht einmal zwei alles noch mechanisch
zu bremsen drin ja also jetzt flugzeug
und dokumente hieß es gerade genau ja
ich habe mir einfach gedacht jetzt immer
mit dem war eine runde gefahren sind
nicht dann machen wir nochmal einen of
school hier okay also
ja weil du ja immer eigentlich vorzüge
gerne seine ja klar also wird sie dann
auch ordentlich ja
das ist der silver spirit zwei geil auch
noch aus also aus besitz ja also es
nicht meinen besitz aber freund von mir
ja und ist einfach wie ich finde ein
traumauto klassiker du hast teppich hat
keine fußmatten und schaltung noch am
lenkrad na das ist der achte ist jetzt
kein neuer phantom wie man sieht auch
keine suicide doors jaja sondern geht
ganz normal auf regen haben in der türe
kam auch erst später liegt hinten drin
sagt mal ehrlich wie viele von euch
kennen das silver spirit habe ich schon
will zwar so oft mir auch mobile
angeschaut wie so ein volltrottel so als
als 18 19 jährige neuer bentley rolls
royce die alte kita
günstig herstellen leute ich meine ich
sie zum traurigen gegenentwurf zum
cinquecento aber es ist eben deswegen
sitzt du das wort richtig es ist halt
ein chauffeurs autor und guck mal hinten
der spiegel ist es ist
ja ja mit der gast wie geil da komme ich
noch ein bisschen hammer ich finde das
unfassbar geil ich ist das geil also da
hast du wirklich jetzt ja der gleitet
durch den verkehr da hast du mich jetzt
wo kommt das cruisen hat er war
das also dass wir das habe ich das
richtig richtig geile überraschung da
schaue ich mal die ganzen details hier
aber den den picknick sagen jetzt musst
du mal fahren so leute jetzt
erstmal
rolls royce fahrersitz ich habe auch das
lacie also viel was mich fahren lasse ja
wie diese tür schließt heute das ja ja
die kleinen schon
in unsere galerie im moment so meine
herrschaften dann will ich sage nochmals
auf die reise und denen den den fährt
man halt auch nicht mit durchdrehenden
rädern also
wirklich geschockt man muss ja auch dann
nur wenn man im all serviert wird muss
man ja auch eine gewisse auch eine
akustische abstand zum möbel haben oder
ich dass ich wegen auch die geräusche
insulation das dämpft alles über uns
auch diese diese lammfell teppiche ja
das ist zwar auch schön und edel aber
die dämpfen auch die dämpfe noch die
geräusche die von unten kommen und alles
ist schon alles durchdacht war ehrlich
ist die bremse ist sehr angenehm wenn
riesen herfahren ja 30 jahre alt ist
hammerhart hammerhart das ist wirklich
ein fall so leid ich kann es euch nur
andere hatten ihr müsst ja wiederum ist
einfach nichts falsches sagen ihr müsst
es klingt immer gut für euch alle
gewollt war das ist das zeichen da freut
sich greta tun merkt mit dem jetzt zu
den verkehr bleibt da ist auch egal wer
schlau ist dann also mir alles egal wenn
ich heute morgen aufgewacht bin mit
10.000 kopfschmerzen über irgendwelche
sachen das alles egal wenn ja dann hey
das ist warum haben wir auch zum
wiedersehen herr kopp wir können
vielleicht mal die motoren
hahaha
da können wir doch mal gucken
ja wir sehen gleich im vergleich zum 14
es ist voll der motorhaube also
mindestens ein achtzylinder ich seh
schon mal 41 28 jahre v8 v8 barcelona ja
das ist ein auto ich weiß jetzt nicht
aus dem kopf aus dem effeff lister um
die zuverlässigkeit im alltag bestellt
ist aber das würde ich sofort im alltag
fahren ja ich auch sofort wie geil wäre
das denn wenn der fest keine ahnung zum
supermarkt zum einkaufen im 2 was für
die zweite nein nein na ja war gerade
ein kleiner fehler okay du wirst gehe
einkaufen zum supermarkt gefahren
okay das ist auch die wahrheit der leute
natürlich sagen ich kam heute hierhin
dachte wir streben portofino und wir
machen das ganz klassisch mit bewertung
am ende und dann sind wir gut gefahren
und dann rolls royce grill hat jetzt zum
abschluss noch mal eine kleine ergänzung
der hat tatsächlich noch unseren fotos
wieder gefunden schau an geil in
greco ferne
ja ich sage mal
schlimmer in den rot fand ich immer gut
kann man ja vielleicht auch mal kurz
noch mal zeigen aber ja er ist natürlich
im moment nicht so nicht so stubenrein
weil wir sehen was wir für ein wetter
haben ja und dann ich schäme mich dann
immer wenn das schon ein bisschen
dreckig war eigentlich nicht aber ich
finde die sitze hat in der farbe das war
ich habe ja selber so konfiguriert mit
allem was dazu gehört auch bremsen und
die farbe das kann man sich alles dann
ja weile aussuchen so das will ich halt
schon schön weil es ein bisschen
individuell wird und ich finde halt
innen ihnen irgendwie roth außen rot
dann ist mir zu es hat jeder mahlzeit
aber das ist so der klassiker also erste
ebene du bist du bist du auf ein typ
also ich weil ich die einstellung macht
auch gerne ein eigenes ding das ich
wollte sagen ein bisschen
personalisieren und das heißt in dem
fall geklappt und was ich halt besonders
mag das können wir heute leider nicht
hinkriegen bei dem wetter offen fahren
ja das ist einfach wunderbar da ist es
auch egal wie viel ps der hat natürlich
ist ein sportwagen aber mir geht es in
erster linie zeige ich auch mal wieder
ich bin kein möchtegern rennfahrer
sondern mir geht's um die ästhetik des
autos das einfach eine wunderbare
ästhetik klar verseucht die formel 1 ein
bisschen aber ich weiß genau auf welche
seite leitplanke ich hingehöre und
deswegen bin ich da auch nicht so hart
am gast sondern genießt einfach das
fahren und damit leute kommen wir ans
ende von diesem wunderschönen video
kleiner vielen dank war ich habe jetzt
privat stoff für die auch ausgelassen
die enttäuscht dass hier nur
verschiedene autos gern anders aber bei
mir ist immer die wundertüte weißt du
was ich bin schon 458 4 88 f8 und roma
aber noch niveau source system haben wir
wieder was gelernt dass ich auch schon
alle gefahren richtig geil überhaupt
alle uns verriet von denen einer ehrlich
gesagt eigentlich der f8 echt ja ich bin
halt 84 als kompromiss zwischen schon
turbo boost haben und aber auch noch
richtig geilen sound also richtig geil
leute habe mich sehr gefreut ich hoffe
dass ich auch gefallen und ja sie sind
vom nächsten dorf werden